[Music]
going diving for the first time was an
incredible
experience
all of a sudden colors are very
different sound seems to come from all
directions
[Music]
on a coral reef life is everywhere
it's just everywhere and from that point
forward i knew
that i really wanted to specialize on
these deeper reef communities
in 2016 we actually saw a major event
that affected coral reefs around the
world
it's estimated that we lost about half
of the coral on the northern great
barrier reef
actually witnessing that bleaching first
hand was a major turning point in my
career
from that point onward i started to feel
a real responsibility to start studying
these reefs
in a way that could more actively
contribute to their survival
[Music]
so my group at the california academy of
sciences uses
imaging and genomic methods to study the
ecology of coral reefs
[Music]
things have changed for us as coral reef
biologists a lot in the past couple of
decades
with genomics and imaging technologies
it's no longer a field science
now it's very much data science
the data that we collect from the field
we need programming languages like r and
python
to analyze our results with these kind
of analysis
we can actually identify the genotypes
within a population that hold most
promise for survival
at the same time we can also see whether
there's enough of those individuals
to really be viable into the future
coral reefs are incredibly important
there's no doubt about that
they host 25 percent of marine species
they provide food and livelihoods to 500
billion people
they contribute billions to a global
economy there's no doubt that coral
reefs are important
with these new technologies i do have
hope
that we can preserve coral reefs for
future generations
[Music]
you